today we're talking about sex sex that
[Music]
been together for six months tomorrow
actually we've been together for three
and a half years we went together
alright
we're not that crazy it was it was like
a month into our relationship that that
we decided to have sex in the in the
bathroom there like public dorm
bathrooms showers that just sounds to me
well it was your ideas I just would like
to point that out we didn't have to do
it in the shower she has a single room
okay so it was like the girls do but she
kept making me be quiet boys it's a
public place and then like two girls
walked in actually yeah we had like just
finished and we were in the showers
though and they were there for like 20
minutes they would not leave and so I'm
just sitting there in the shower like
all right we're just chilling here I
didn't have a problem with it they
probably would have just been like way
to go like its appearance because she's
the RA of that hall that's so like yeah
I guess like her walking out and seeing
them seeing their RA with the dude in
the bathroom like that's bad so I was
like you can't see me
you cannot leave if I say you're okay to
leave right yeah like I got out of the
bathroom the girls were there and I was
like I'm gonna go out shut up
when they left I was like okay let's go
he's like I don't owl I mean my room was
right across through the bathroom but it
was like sprint it's a naked man running
out of the girls bathroom at like 2:00
a.m. there's a mess it wasn't mess and
it was unnecessary I swear I'm not like
that like I did a good she's like that
you can sort all you want but you're
like the first one that comes to mind
for both of us is a tour bus like in a
bunk a very small bag it's like it's
like a coffin and there's also
11 other people within earshot of you
like so not only do you physically have
to get very creative but you also have
to be extremely quiet
I don't think maybe they did and they
were just very polite we did it plenty
of times after that I think we're just
describing the first instance of many
yeah it definitely wasn't wondering
there's only like one story in mind cuz
kind of a little vanilla with some
chocolate chips
I like that swirl in there that gets you
to you know I can say it was like two or
three months ago that I didn't want to
say we're because maybe we're supposed
having sex over there
we weren't hiking like a lot it looks
like a hike okay don't undermine the two
miles that we walked so there was like
the trail people walking those bushes
and then there was like an entire open
field I started on the bench remember we
sat on a bench and I think and then
there was like a path to way so we
decided to move that's what we walked
again there's definite families and kids
like everyone other yes there were
totally yeah they were traveling kids'll
be playing ice I saw them for sure
enough like okay I mean that's like the
adrenaline I was there yeah this is hot
people are watching nobody's something
no I don't think so
no I would not do the bathroom again I'm
down for anything
I'm down for anywhere anytime we do it
again I will have sex again on a tour
bus with Timothy a will oh yes I will
talk about of the early us like we need
to have sex more crazier places so we
have more stories come on you got to be
like rocky road
[Music]